toward the end of the book i start
talking about what our cure for aging is
actually going to look like and i think
it's going to be
much more complicated than anything
we've talked about so far the reason
i've got some faith that it's going to
happen
is because we're undergoing a
computational revolution in biology at
the moment you know even if we don't get
to general intelligence i think we're
going to get to a point where ai
programs are able to interpret this huge
sort of torrent of data that biologists
are producing in a way that humans just
can't understand
what is aging
that is an excellent question there are
many many different ways you could
define this and i think
every different scientist to give you a
different answer but i've got two ways
of thinking about it one of them
statistical one of them biological
and the statistical way of thinking
about it which i think is the most sort
of casual definition of aging
is it's what happens to your risk of
death with time so the longer you've
been alive
how much does your risk of death
increase so take the example of humans
um if you're in your 30s your risk of
death is about why in a thousand per
year
if you're lucky enough to make it as far
as 80 your risk of death goes up to five
percent a year so it's
you know hundreds of times more and what
uh yes
so what that means actually if you look
at the stats is can i start that again
cause i think it's not hundreds of times
is it the difference between five and a
thousand is only it's
200. it's 200 times why i'm right
so it's fine it's correct it's correct
andrew
the internet you're here because you're
a scientist not because you're a
mathematician
and what you find actually is that the
better people are at maths in terms of
like
the proper theoretical hardcore maths
the worst they are at mental maths
and you find yourself second guessing
yourself all the time if you get a
proper hardcore number theorist
they can't add two and five i remember
my so that my old housemate did a phd in
pure mathematics
and he once ordered a four-seater taxi
for five of us because apparently in
pure math you count from zero
yeah yeah it's off by one error classic
and computer programming as well
unbelievable man you spend all this time
doing maths you can't count to five
when i got a phd can't even manage it so
what
was that yeah so the so humans that
there's a way to sum up all that stuff
that i just failed out of in my head
is that our risk of death doubles every
eight years so you can say in some sense
our rate of aging
is encapsulated in this number we're
saying that if that's you know this is
called the mortality rate doubling time
so how long does it take your mortality
rate to double and if you look around
the animal kingdom this isn't universal
at all for mice
it's a matter of months um but if you
look at something like a giant tortoise
which you'll find on the cover of my
book and the reason is that they're
what's called negligibly senescent
they have a risk of death which is
constant with time so effectively their
mortality rate doubling time is infinite
and that doesn't mean they're immortal
it doesn't mean they're going to live
forever but what it does mean is it
doesn't matter how long ago they were
born
their risk of death stays the same so
that's the statistical definition of
death
the biological deficit sorry of aging
the biological definition of aging i'd
say
is to look at the individual components
of the aging process and there was a
paper published in 2013 called the
hallmarks of aging
and it lists these nine different
changes in your cells and your molecules
um and they they tend to increase with
age all of these things
um they tend to if you accelerate these
changes then the animals will have their
aging accelerators they'll die more
quickly
and if you slow these changes down then
the animals get less disease and die
more slowly
so that's the sort of criteria by which
they define these different hallmarks
which are sort of more nitty-gritty
molecular what's actually going on
definition of aging as opposed to that
high level statistical what we started
with yeah
is there a cultural blind spot around
aging like hearing the word
cure and aging in the same sentence is
not very common yeah i think there is
and i've
i've used the word cure slightly to the
chagrin of some of the scientists who
read the book actually
um because it is a bit of a
controversial way of putting it but the
reason i want to put it that way
isn't necessarily because i think a cure
is just around the corner but it's
because i want to normalize the idea
that aging is something that should be
cured
i think there's an interesting
discussion as to whether it's you know
should be classified as a disease or not
but nonetheless whatever it is whether
you think of it as a disease or whether
you just think of it as a sort of
a disease syndrome i've heard scientists
describe it as or if you just think of
it as a natural
process the fact is it means that we get
much more likely to get diseases
we get much frailer we lose our mental
faculties none of those things are good
things
and i think to try to cure them to at
least aim for that target is where we
should be going with medicine are there
not things
we need to sort out first like cancer
and heart disease
like surely they're easier to fix and
quicker to happen than
than aging yeah the strange the strange
thing is
it might actually be easier to sort
aging than to sort all of those diseases
individually
so the reason that our risk of death
doubles every eight years as it does
um you've got to die of something right
you don't just like drop dead in the
street with no underlying cause
and the things that you die of are
actually exactly the diseases you just
listed cancer heart disease stroke
dementia
all of these terrible diseases which are
primarily suffered from by old people
you know a few people in their 30s do
get diagnosed with cancer
but by and large it's people in their
60s and their 70s and their 80s
and the risk of all of these diseases
rises in exactly the same sort of
terrifying exponential way with time
and that's because it's all the same
biological processes they drive wrinkles
they drive grey hair so they're sort of
superficial changes
they drive the loss of muscle mass that
makes it harder to do stuff around the
house the frailty
but they also drive the cancer the heart
disease the dementia etc
and actually um if you look at the the
international classification of diseases
is this massive
sort of attempt by scientists and
doctors to assign a code to everything
that can go wrong with your body
and there are about i think there are 11
000 of these in the latest edition i
might have got that slightly wrong it's
you know it's thousands and thousands of
different ways that you can go wrong
it's a bit depressing
when you think of it like that but a
significant fraction of these
are basically aging you know they're
things that their cancer there's
loads you know every single subtype of
every cancer in every organ there's all
the different ways that your heart or
your circulation can go wrong with
everything that can happen in your brain
all the different kinds of dementia
so we can either as scientists and
doctors go after these
thousands of individual causes or we can
go after the root cause the thing that
causes all of us to all of those
diseases
and that's aging and so although you
know aging's not going to be an easy
thing to crack it's going to be you know
there's some research still needed it's
quite possibly going to be easier than
taking out every single one of those
possible ways your body can go wrong all
at the same time yeah
you said much of modern medicine targets
symptoms a few steps removed from the
root cause of the illness
i guess it relates to what you're
talking about there
exactly yeah and i think that our it's
sort of natural because the way we used
to treat infectious diseases you'd get
uh
you know you'd get measles and what you
need to do is either vaccinate people so
they don't get the
so they can fight off the virus before
it becomes an infection or you need to
treat them in some way and if it's a
bacterial infection you can give them
antibiotics and once you've got rid of
the disease from the body you've cured
it
but with something like cancer you can
even if we had a cure for cancer right
we could remove the cancer from the body
perhaps very successfully
but then it would still in essence be an
old body that you're left with a body
with a huge risk of developing another
cancer
a body with a huge risk of heart disease
already already has heart disease
already has the beginnings of dementia
and so by treating the diseases these
sort of atoms these individual entities
that are separate from the processes
going on the rest of the body
um it's just an approach that's doomed
to failure ultimately yeah i was
interested
to look at the average life expectancy
work that you'd done um and i think it
was
35 years old about sort of 20 000 30 000
years ago classic hunter gatherer
uh and only 200 years ago the average
life expectancy was 40
in the uk which that blew me away but
you highlight an interesting uh quirk i
guess of statistical science
that that is skewed massively by infant
mortality
that you've got ridiculous volumes i
think was it like
you only had a 60 chance of making it to
18 20 000 years ago something like that
yes it's hard to get the exact numbers
that's the sort of ballpark yeah it's
basically like tossing a coin to see if
you'll make your 21st birthday
which is ridiculous to modernize like
imagine if we were running that sort of
gauntlet in our
childhood and teens it's crazy yeah yeah
that was mad
so one question that i became fascinated
by and i've had
david sinclair and andrew scott talking
about longevity on the show before
and i didn't even think to ask them this
question is there a purpose
to dying i thought that we were supposed
to be adaptive fitness maximizers right
and surely this certain end to life
is a bit of an error like what why is
evolution not made us immortal
yeah it's an interesting question and
there's so there are two aspects to this
firstly is there
an adaptive advantage to dying and
secondly is there an adaptive advantage
to aging which is sort of
they sound like they're the same
question but they're not um so to
answer the question about death there
could be an argument that the reason
that creatures die
is because evolution um it can only
happen between
generations right you and i we've got
our dna that was you know half of our
mum half from my dad
and that dna is what we're stuck with
for life you know more or less
we can't you know adapt to be better
faster stronger we can obviously we can
train we can eat well we can do whatever
we like to try and improve our fitness
but ultimately we're stuck with the
genes that we've got so if you want to
evolve you've got to have kids and those
kids will differ from you in a few
different ways you know different the
partner you had the children with
and it's through these tiny differences
maybe that will give your kid a slight
evolutionary advantage over the kids of
the
people next door and over generations
and generations whatever
you know properties your child had that
made them fitter in that environment
will cause them to evolve so the problem
is if you have an organism
that doesn't die how does it evolve
because it can't unless it can you know
go in and change its own dna which isn't
a thing that organisms can do
the changes in dna occurred due to birth
not death
dying doesn't seem to be a part of
reproduction
no it's not but imagine so imagine that
where you know cheetahs out on the
savannah
and we're really well adapted for our
particular uh evolutionary niche we're
really good at running fast
and then we're and we're also immortal
cheetah so this is a this is a
lovely experiment shall we say um so
we're immortal cheaters running around
on the savannah you know eating gazelles
the problem is say for example there's a
there's a massive famine of the
particular kind
of tree that the gazelles we most like
to eat eat and so all the gazelles die
and we the ones you know
we the handful are still left suddenly
um what we need to do is adapt our
environment's dramatically changed we
haven't got any cells to it anymore
but because we have got our fixed dna we
can't adapt we've still got sharp teeth
we're still you know
adapted to run quickly and catch stuff
we're still adapted to digest meat
and the only way that we could adapt
would be to do that over evolutionary
time so perhaps our kids are slightly
better at eating leaves than we were
and so they can slowly move away and
perhaps get an omnivorous diet so they
can eat meat and leaves then eventually
they might become completely vegetarian
this is a slightly ridiculous thought
experiment but the point being
once you're in existence if you just
don't die you can't adapt to your
changing environment
and so it's it's actually a point of
contention how important a fact this is
but it's definitely possible that a
literally immortal species just couldn't
evolve and so as soon as the world you
know the world would change around it
and it'll be doomed that way yeah
i've been fascinated i went to uh dubai
earlier this year and i went to the
marina and saw a huge
crocodile sorry an alligator that they'd
taken from god knows where
and i was reading about how alligators
and sharks basically looked out
with their uh adaptive properties and
they've
essentially unchanged for millions and
millions and millions of years they just
landed perfectly
on their evolutionary niche as you
called it and i guess that that would be
the only way that you'd be able to
survive
that the role of the dice would be like
26s in a row
you're like yes i got the teeth i needed
and the
hide i needed and the legs i needed and
everything and also this environment
better not change
yeah exactly and as soon as you know we
could imagine something like climate
change could certainly push certain
sharks out of existence just because
they've been
adapted for this environment for
millions and millions of years but if we
come along and change it too quickly or
an external factor comes along and
changes it
they might not be adapted anymore and so
yeah that could be the end of those
living fossils what's the other
half of why we die then in terms of
evolution
so in terms of evolution um aging is an
accident and so you're absolutely right
to sort of couch in terms of
evolution is designed to maximize
fitness and that isn't always quite in
the way that you expect
in that it doesn't always mean that
you're going to be bigger faster
stronger
because obviously i don't you know
otherwise animals would slowly evolve to
become huge
monsters and they clearly don't do that
right they optimize themselves to for
their current environment
and so that might mean occasionally it
makes a change that doesn't seem like
it's making the animal fitter like for
example again if we're back to our
cheetahs not immortal anymore
but we're back to our cheetahs on the
savannah there is probably a point at
which there's no point running any
faster
because what that means is that you're
going to spend energy building bigger
muscles and stronger bones in order to
be able to run more quickly
but if you can already run faster than
all your prey you're effectively wasting
that energy
and you could be using that energy for
something else evolutionarily
so you could be using it to you know
make your first slightly better
camouflage or you could be using it to
have more kids
and so all of these things are ways to
redirect your energy away from sort of
the
the naive conception of what fitness
means
because i think as you know we often
imagine fitness to mean big hard strong
animals
but that's not always the case you know
we've got frogs we've got insects we've
got all things that are tiny and
strong and weak and all different kinds
of um animals adapted very differently
for different environments
so aging is exactly the same sort of
thing in this it's an evolutionary
compromise because if you build an
animal that's effectively immortal
um so it doesn't you know has a risk of
death it doesn't change with time for
example
it's got to put energy into being
immortal it's got to put energy into
maintaining its body it's got to make
put energy into making sure that no
cancers
start off and it's got to have an immune
system that's constantly patrolling
looking out for those cancers
and all of these different um sort of
ways to spend that energy
it could be spent in other ways you
could spend it having an extra kid
or you could spend it um having slightly
stronger muscles again to catch up with
those gazelles so there's this sort of
as as an organism you're trying to
choose between
uh you're trying to optimize across all
these different parts of your body and
that could be longevity that could be
how strong your muscles are that could
be how tall you are depending on the
environment you're in
and longevity isn't always going to be
the winner so even though you might
expect
the big biggest fastest strongest
longest lived animal to always win
sometimes the short lived one's going to
win because it puts less energy into
maintaining its body and it can put more
energy into something that's more
evolutionarily important in its niche
it's like a malthusian trap a little bit
it's like um
you're going to be out competed by
something else that has a more
a higher chance of not only surviving
but also reproducing
and if your survival is at the uh cost
of your reproduction like it's not
happening
yeah that's exactly right and i think
this this phrase survival of the fittest
it's really become like a part of
popular culture
but actually what we should say about
evolution is it's reproduction of the
fittest
that's the key point because it doesn't
matter if you survive you can survive
but if you don't reproduce
any traits you have have been competed
out of the gene pool
exactly and like at some point a bus or
a
you know or a cheater is going to come
along and get you and you're gone
you might as well not exist i'll tell
you what i found out this year that i
thought was fascinating it's the
uh non-zero existential risk from
natural risks that we have that means we
have to have technological progress
so this is from uh toby odds the
precipice
and there's a lot of concerns at the
moment around
are we moving too quickly towards
artificial general intelligence or bio
weapons or nano technology and we're all
going to get turned into grey sludge or
paper clips or whatever the next thought
experiment is
but what he did say is there is a
non-zero chance that we're going to be
killed eventually if you stuck around
for long enough
we're going to be hit by an asteroid or
a super volcano is going to go off or
the sun's going to swallow us or
something
so we need technological progress and
it's kind of the same as we're seeing
in evolution right that's just like a
macro aggregated version
you need to have this cost payoff
between the two
yeah definitely and i think that's
that's exactly right because there are
some problems that we can't evolve our
way out of
like if we just not if we hadn't
developed computers and spacecraft and
all these different things
like what on earth are we gonna do in a
billion years when the sun starts
getting a bit bigger and hotter and the
earth just gets toasted and all the
oceans boil
like there's no level of um natural
living evolution that's going to get us
out of that situation so
fingers crossed that we can sort it out
ourselves so why do we age
fundamentally that's exactly why it's
this trait this evolutionary trade-off
and what that means what that means is
that our bodies in a variety of ways
have decided not to
put as much energy into maintaining our
uh physique as they could as we get
older
and so the idea is that you know if i
were to
put all that energy into maintaining my
body i would have fewer kids
you might have more kids because you put
less energy into maintaining your body
from an evolutionary perspective
and your two kids are eventually gonna
mean that they have four kids and they
have eight kids whereas my one kid's
only gonna have two kids it's constantly
going to be a step behind
and that means that in an environment
where you know eventually i'm going to
get hit by a bus or i'm going to get
eaten by a saber-toothed cat or you know
just going to die of an infection in
prehistory
then your weight of numbers is going to
outweigh my
slight extra lifespan advantage and
ultimately evolution makes this trade
off
and unfortunately it's uh come down with
us aging what's the process
of us aging what what is happening
inside why does it
why does it do what it does it's a
variety of different things it is
basically
a load of things falling out of balance
a load of things getting broken
and um it's it's it's quite a
complicated thing right so i think
there's um
there's there have been a lot of
theories of asian that have tried to
ascribe it to a single cause
but i think what the hallmarks show us
and i talk about the hallmarks of my
book in a slightly modified form they've
got nine i've got 10 i sort of i
combined a couple of hours an extra
couple
but it's basically the same kind of
thing because obviously the process
is um is very similar but it's
everything from
the dna inside our cells getting damaged
um to the populations of cells falling
out of kilter
to certain molecules being damaged and
never being repaired to signals that
change that cause cells behavior to
change
so it's a complicated sort of processes
upon processes upon processes
which ultimately mean that um the
environment inside our body is very
different by the time we're 60 or 70 or
80 than it is when we're 20 or 30.
and that is what causes us to age
fundamentally it's bizarre isn't it
because
i think we're not conscious of the fact
that our cells are constantly
replacing themselves i think is it every
seven years you don't have a cell left
in your body that was there seven years
ago is that right
so it depends on the tissue it's really
interesting because like so our guts
are literally turning over every few
days and
our red blood cells in our blood they
last about three or four months
but then if you look in other parts of
the body bones i think probably are on
about the seven or ten year mark
but if you look at some neurons in the
brain and some heart cells
you are literally born with them and die
with them so they last your entire life
and it's actually really fascinating why
these different organs have chosen
these different sort of levels of
turnover because obviously
in an environment like your guts it's
rough and tumbling there you're getting
lots of toxins in your food you've got
bacteria you've got your microbiome
all sorts of stuff going on and clearly
evolution has decided the optimal way to
deal with that is to constantly replace
those cells
whereas in your brain it's um it's all
protected there's something called the
blood-brain barrier that keeps almost
everything out of your brain that isn't
needed
and that means that a neuron is in a
really quite a safe environment
and so apart from a few special cases
like your the olfactory neurons the
neurons that are responsible for your
sense of smell
they turn over really rapidly because
they're um exposed to the outside
environment basically they're exposed to
all kinds of dangers
whereas a neuron that's like deep
somewhere inside your skull is so well
protected
the evolution for whatever reason has
decided it's better to leave that neuron
completely intact and never change it
for your whole life
that's fascinating i thought i've seen
something probably on instagram
that was like every seven years or so
your all of your cells turn over
but now everybody that's listening has
it in the tank
to say actually there's a there's some
neurons are in the blood
brain barrier and i think you'll find
they're exactly the same um
so did your research uncover any animals
that live for ridiculous periods of time
obviously we know our life expectancy at
the moment
what about other animals i think the
craziest
in terms of actual lifespan tend to be a
little bit further from humans
so the longest lived vertebrate which
means animals with a backbone is
actually kind of shark
called the greenland shark and it's hard
to be exactly sure of their age because
it's not as though we've like
tagged a shark 400 years ago and then
like watched it until it died
but they think from various sort of
chemical analysis that the oldest
greenland shark ever found was about 400
years old
so that's crazy but then as you move a
bit further away from us in
the sort of tree of evolution and the
tree was an appropriate choice of word
actually because we think the longest
lived single organism on the planet is a
tree called a bristlecone pine
um it's in the white mountains in
california it's a top-secret location
because they want vandals to go and chop
down this like
incredible piece of earth history it's a
secret tree
[ __ ] the bed yeah i see a secret tree
um and it's they think it's about 4850
years old they took a core out of it and
they counted the rings just as you know
tree rings just as you'd expect
and it was i think it was about 4800 in
the 1950s
and so sort of moving that forward that
tree
was a sapling before the pyramids like
that's just absolutely mind-blowing to
me that that tree has basically seen the
whole arc of human civilization
from atop this sort of windy arid
mountaintop in california
that's unreal what about this hydra
thing
hydra fascinating that's another example
i was going to suggest actually and
that's another one where we don't
actually know how long they live
but we can extrapolate from how long how
long we've watched like loads of them
live
to how how many would still be alive
after a really long time
so hydra they're these tiny freshwater
creatures they're incredibly simple so
they basically got a mouth at one end
and a bum at the other and not
not a great deal else going on um and
the the thing that really captured
scientists attention about them
initially
was that you can chop any bit off a
hydra and it will turn into a new hydra
so you can chop it in half you'll get
too high you can chop it into four
you'll get four hydra
and so has this incredible you know if
you if you think salamanders are good at
regenerating
it's got nothing on a hydra you know you
can't chop a salamander's leg off
they'll get a new leg but the leg won't
go into a new salamander
so they've got this incredible power of
regeneration
and um as scientists started watching
them more in the lab they realized
they're actually living a surprisingly
long time as well
and um it's been extrapolated again we
obviously haven't done the actual
full-length experiment
that 10 of hydra would still be living
after a thousand years
if the death rates we've observed so far
are accurate
which is just bonkers because there's we
we sort of imagine the bigger
and more complicated and more human-like
and organism is the longer it's going to
live like
in general as a rule of thumb but these
are literally like
microscopic organisms and they can live
a thousand years is this like
tardigrades as well they're pretty
hardcore aren't they
they are pretty hardcore i actually
don't know if we've got any good
longevity data
tardigrades i've not seen it they're
certainly hardcore in the sense that
they can like
survive ridiculous environments insane
levels of radiation
vacuum terrible chemicals and they just
basically
um i think they just um dehydrate
themselves and turn themselves into this
like
super hardcore remnant tardigrade that
as soon as you just you just add water
you get the type yeah it is like those
sea monkeys that used to get as a kid
yeah
you said that the effect of fasting is
one of the most universal in all of
biology
what's that mean so we've observed the
first proof that we had that aging could
be changed in animals
were some experiments that were that
they were sort of kicking off a bit
around the early 20th century but the
first proper formal
uh experiment on this was done in the
1930s by a guy called clyde mackay
he was looking at rat development and he
was really fascinated by
if you feed rats different amounts of
food but you give them make sure they
get the right amount of nutrients
but you feed them different numbers of
calories what does that do primarily
actually to their development because
back in those days people weren't living
quite so long i think there's more of a
focus on the beginning of life optimal
nutrition when you're growing up sort of
stuff
but what they noticed was in these
experiments that the rats that were
given substantially less food
and we're not talking like a diet here
we're talking like half the amount of
food that the other arts were being
given
um they just kept living so they were
they lived about 40
no hang on they lived about 80 longer
than us um
and they not only did they live longer
they live longer in good health so these
rats that were dying
almost twice as late as the rats that
were eating a normal diet
um when they did an autopsy after those
rats were dead they basically looked the
same they looked indistinguishable
from the rats that had died you know 600
days previously to cut in a couple of
years previously
um and what that suggests is that this
process was slowing the aging process
down by you know by eating less you slow
down aging
and we've since discovered this works in
all kinds of different organisms ranging
from yeast so the stuff that used to
make beer
um all the way up through flies and mice
and dogs and
you know bizarre creatures that live in
pond water
and the only question mark really is
over how to what extent it works in
humans
and we've got some experiments in
monkeys that show that it certainly
makes
them live healthier but it doesn't seem
to make them live longer
so it's this really fascinating
universal effect but
one of the things i found most
infuriating reading about this because i
was thinking can i do this and
on the one hand i almost certainly can't
because i just like food too much to be
totally honest you know
i've tried doing a bit of fasting i just
get very very hungry i get very grumpy
you know it's not a good look um but the
second thing is
that it's hard to motivate yourself to
do something so difficult
when the evidence is so mixed for humans
and we just don't know
whether you're going to be putting
yourself that so there's this sort of
joke in the biogerontology community
um fasting doesn't actually make you
live longer but it certainly feels like
longer
and so you don't want to you don't want
to get yourself in a position where
you're putting yourself through absolute
hell
feeling hungry literally all the time
and then you know you get to the age of
80
drop dead exactly on cue and the
scientists announced all you know we've
done the study now we've
got the dietary restriction works and
every other organism apart from us
where's your
money on this if you had to
put a bet on i think it's probably going
to turn out that it improves health but
doesn't do that much on lifespan
i'm not going to say it wouldn't give
you a year or two but it's not going
because and i think the the best
evidence for this quite a sarge many
like complicated
studies because there have been attempts
to do this properly proper medical
research
type randomized trials where you give
some people you might you know
reduce some people's diets and leave
other people eating normally and see
what the difference is
um but quite apart from these sort of
you know proper high octane studies
the fact is you look around the world
there are people in different religions
people in different cultures
we've got such a variety of diets
globally and the fact is
there's nobody living to 150. um so what
that probably suggests is that there's
nothing we can really do to our diets or
our lifestyles within reason
that's going to have a dramatic effect
on our lifespan
it would be i mean for the longevit r
longevity
on reddit if if it's true that fasting
doesn't do anything there are a lot of
people i mean
they've spent half the amount of money
on food that they would have done but
it's that bonus yeah
potentially been twice as hungry so yeah
it is a big trade-off
um just going back to that rat study
there was calorie restriction and
fasting
are two different things you can eat
half the amount of food
just as frequently or you can eat less
food or a similar amount of food
less frequently or more frequently how
what are the effects that was seen from
that
so this is this is so naughty and i
think there's a real problem actually
with the
animal experiments so mice is the one
that they've they've done a bit more
experimentation in now they're the more
common lab animal
and um there's they've been you know
scientists trying to distinguish the
effects between dietary restrictions so
eating less all the time
and intermittent fasting and that again
this can come in a huge load of forms
like do you eat every other day
do you do the 5-2 diet any five days a
week and take two non-consecutive days
off
do you go for a week without food every
few months like there's just a huge
spectrum there's even this
16-8 um time-restricted feeding idea
where you only eat during an eight-hour
window during the day
um so there's just this huge range of
different things to test
and i think there's a worry in in the
science community that actually the
mouse experiments haven't tested any of
these things very reliably
the reason being mice are nocturnal and
phd students are not
nocturnal so the way that the phd
students tend to feed the mice
is they'll go in at the end of their end
of the work day
give them their ration so half their
food if they're on dietary restriction
or their food you know whatever they
want if they're
eating what they like and then they'll
come back the next morning and the food
will be gone
and if you actually watch the mice that
are doing that the mice that are on
dietary restriction they're starving
so they run in they eat all their food
in one go and then they don't eat for 23
hours
so effectively they're doing sort of
this weird combination of dietary
restriction and intermittent fasting
and it astonished me i was chatting to a
scientist about this and they were
saying actually
so this is obviously we've recognized
this problem and just now
like literally in the last few years
they've started doing some experiments i
don't think any have yet been published
with automated feeders like you get for
your dog or your cat if you're away from
home
and it just i just it's head slapping
like have they only thought it's not as
though this is
2010 technology you know we've had
automated pet feeders for decades
haven't we
and yet for the first time you know
there's been enough interest in sort of
distinguishing the differences between
dr and if to actually do the experiment
properly and find out
we only put wheels on luggage about 30
years ago
so if that's if that's a stat to remind
us just how [ __ ] we are at innovation
sometimes then that's all we need so how
can we treat aging we've
said it's a big problem we've said that
downstream risks from it are essentially
endless
it is the how would you say
it is the axis of so much suffering in
life right like if you live for long
enough all of the people that you care
about
all of the people who care about you are
going to die and it's going to be
incredibly traumatic so obviously
holding that off or stopping it entirely
would be a universal good
how can we treat it where do we start i
think the way to start is to look at the
hallmarks of aging and to look at ways
to slow and reverse those
and my favorite example because it's the
one that's furthest forward and it's
quite an intuitive one is looking at
senescent cells
which you might have heard of before so
these cells um they were first
discovered in the 60s
and they were discovered by a guy called
leonard hayflick and he was doing these
are very sort of
cells in addition experiments they're
very far removed from actual you know
organisms and humans
he was just growing these cells in a
dish and what he noticed was they divide
and divide and divide what cells do
and then after about 50 divisions they'd
just stop
and not only did they stop dividing they
looked weird under the microscope they
started out as these quite sort of
ordered looking things
but if you look at a senescent cell even
you know a non-expert can see it's this
sort of
weird blurgy splayed out look you know
it looks
radically different from a non-senescent
cell and as a result
because these cells seem to be old in
the sense they divided a lot of times
and because they looked weird and
because they stopped dividing they were
christened senescent
and senescent is just a scientific term
for aging basically so it's aged cells
and these were of interest and people
wondered you know that that's
the train of thought in motion could it
be that the aging of our bodies
is driven by the aging of the cells
inside them could it be that cells
inside us
have divided too many times when we get
to the age of 60 or 70 or 80
and that's one of the drivers of the
aging process and so this was sort of
observed for the next few decades
but i think the real excitement about
this started in 2011
when for the first time some scientists
got um at the mayo clinic in the u.s
got uh some mice that have been
genetically modified and they've been
genetically modified such that they had
an extra gene and what that gene did was
it meant if they were given a drug which
is otherwise
uh pretty you know it's innocuous it's
something that if you and me took
nothing would happen because we haven't
got this special gene
but if you do have this special gene in
your cells then
the gene basically goes am i in a
senescent cell if i am
i'm going to kill it so it's sort of a
suicide switch but just for senescent
cells
and so the mice took this drug activated
the gene and the senescent cells in
their bodies committed suicide
and what they found was this made the
mice healthier actually it didn't make
them live longer because this first
experiment was done in a special
and they had another genetic
modification that made them age really
quickly and so they all die after six
months basically
so that that wasn't the big result the
big result was that it made them
healthier
and so then subsequent experiments
started doing this in normal mice that
didn't have this premature aging
condition
and what they found was they can make
them live longer they can make them live
healthier
um they get cancer later they get
cataracts later they they have better
fur which is obviously crucially
important to all of us
um they are you know they're more
cognitively
they they age cognitively more slowly so
if you get one of these mice
and put it into a maze a young mouse
will be very curious and go exploring
whereas an old mouse will be a bit more
nervous and probably not going you know
run around and have a look to see what's
going on
but an old mouse that's been given these
synalytic drugs drugs that kill
senescent cells
is much more like a young mouse it's
more curious it's looking around and so
it seems from what we know so far
that removing these cells globally
reverses the aging process
and the idea would be then this is one
hallmark of aging if we can go after the
rest of them
then we can start to slow and reverse
aging in a multitude of different ways
and all together that should slow our
aging down basically overall
i'm going to guess that just getting the
old out isn't sufficient there must be
something new that needs to be put in to
replace that
how does that how does that sort of fit
in so in the case of the senescent cells
um it'll be interesting to see if this
pans out like in every part of your body
because there might be some places where
exactly as you say getting rid of the
old thing doesn't
isn't sufficient say for example you're
just saying that neurons uh you have
your neurons your whole life
if you were to kill your senescent
neurons then that's really bad news
right you're going to start losing brain
very rapidly and there's nothing to
replenish it
however if you kill the senescent cells
in your skin or your guts or your blood
none of these are really a problem
because they're constantly refreshing
then other cells are just going to
divide take their place and so
you know they're going to very very
rapidly replenish those senescent cells
that have been killed
so it really depends on the part of the
body and yes we probably will have to
replace cells in some of those places
but what's surprising or is it was
almost how lucky we've got with these
first round of synthetic treatments
in that they're imperfect they don't
kill all the senescent cells and we are
just naively killing cells
and yet it seems to make the mice live
longer live younger
i don't think this is going to this is
going to be the end of analytics i think
we're going to have to refine them
but we have struck surprisingly lucky at
least in mice with these first
treatments what about stem cells
yeah we're definitely going to need more
of those i think um
yeah so they're a particular example if
you were to
say a large number of your stem cells
became senescent and you killed them
then you might end up with a problem
because you'd end up with uh what's
called stem cell exhaustion
and um so what we're gonna have to do
there is stem cell therapy effectively
we're gonna have to go into the body
and replace those stem cells with new
fresh versions that are able to keep
your tissues
you know turning over at the rate they
should be turning over it's going to be
a
increasingly complex system
to continue to move what about like
ongoing repair running is there anything
we can do there
yeah and i mean the thing is this this
applies just across all the hallmarks of
aging and it depends
how you choose to tackle each one of
them so with the senescent cells
i think probably getting rid of them is
the most promising approach
but it might be that repairing them is
another option and there are various
ways that you can go about repairing
them as well
so um one thing you can do for example
you've probably heard of the epigenetic
clock i think you chatted with david
sinclair about that
and um the sorts of uh treatment that he
works on
where you insert these genes and it
reverses the apogenic clock can reverse
cellular senescence as well
and it'll be interesting to see whether
or not that's a wise move because often
senescent cells have gone senescent for
a reason
the reason they stop dividing is because
they are at risk of turning cancerous or
because they're badly damaged or broken
in some other way
but it might be that rather than killing
every single senescent cell there are
some that we want to rescue
or there are some that we want to
replenish and i think it's really going
to vary on a case-by-case basis exactly
like you say
is it's complicated it's not going to be
as simple as taking a single pill that
slows or reverses your aging
it's going to be a question of managing
all these different effects perhaps in
different ways in different parts of the
body
in order to make sure that we can
maintain young bodies overall
rather than adding a gene on is there a
way to
upgrade genes wholesale
yeah so gene therapy is coming on it's
not quite at the point where we can
you know inject a new gene into every
cell of your body yet that's a real
challenge
but certainly the dream is that you can
you'll be able to turn jeans off
and turn jeans on put new genes in put
new copies of genes in
and all of these things are certainly
possible in the lab and they're becoming
more possible in humans so i was really
excited last week as we record this
i saw a story about um the first gene
therapy for something called sickle cell
anemia
which is a condition that's particularly
common in people of african descent
and the reason for that is that it's um
it creates a a sort of distorted form of
hemoglobin which is the protein that
carries the oxygen in your blood
and what that form of hemoglobin does is
it creates um sickle shaped so sort of
shaped like a
cyclist in a hammer and sickle so c
letter c shaped cells
um and they're very they're not very
good at catching oxygen carrying oxygen
because they've got a much smaller
volume than a normal round blood cell
and they also tend to get jammed up in
really small blood vessels so the tiny
capillaries they can jam it up and stop
the blood flow entirely
which can cause incredible amounts of
pain for people who have two copies of
this gene because if all their cells are
sickle cells
they're not getting the amount of oxygen
to their tissues sometimes it gets
jammed up entirely it's a really really
terrible disease
the reason it's endemic in africa is
because having one copy of this gene is
actually quite good news
if you're in a population that is
historically affected by malaria
because these sickle cell can
effectively jam up the mosquitoes
um bite proboscis i think is the word
i'm not entirely sure i'm not not an
insect
biologist but you know so it jams up the
mosquitoes and they're unable to take a
drink of blood from you and they're
unable to infect you with a malaria
parasite so that's why this evolved
but now in the modern world it's
becoming less and less important in fact
as i say if you have two of these
genes it's very bad for you anyway long
story short
the scientists have come up with a way
of extracting the stem cells from your
bone marrow which is the place that your
blood cells are regenerated
they then reactivate a gene for
something called fetal hemoglobin so we
have a different kind of hemoglobin that
works when we're inside our mother's
wombs
and they reactivate that gene which is
normally deactivated in adults
and then re-insert those blood cells and
not only that like in the intervening
time they get rid of all the other blood
cells
um all the other blood stem cells with
chemotherapy so at the moment it's not a
hugely pleasant procedure
but then they inject these new cells
back in with this gene reactivated and
they're able to produce blood cells that
are normal again so they lose these
symptoms of the sickle cell anemia and
it works it's just been
i i think it's the first successful
trial i'm not sure it's been approved
yet
but it's just that's just so exciting
because it's an example of um
a lot of the kinds of technologies that
i talk about in my book like you know
removing cells
modifying them outside the body doing
gene therapy putting them back in
it's not at the stage where we can you
know enact all of the ideas that i talk
about in the book
but it's certainly a serious step along
the way to having actual gene therapy
and actual cell therapy in the clinic
will the cure for aging arrive in time
for me and you
i think it could do i don't want to make
any guarantees but i think
what i what i find most remarkable about
this and i i toward the end of the book
i start talking about what our cure for
aging is actually going to look like
and i think it's going to be much more
complicated than anything we've talked
about so far
it's going to be more complicated than
addressing those 10 hallmarks of aging
the reason i've got some faith that it's
going to happen
is because we're undergoing a
computational revolution in biology at
the moment you talked about
ai earlier um you know even if we don't
get to general intelligence i think
we're going to get to a point where ai
programs are able to interpret this huge
sort of torrent of data that biologists
are producing
in in a way that humans just can't
understand and to give another
exciting thing that's happened in the
last couple of weeks deepmind uh this
company that a part of google
announced that they've managed to get ai
to fold proteins to work out how
biological molecules fold up in our
bodies which has been a problem that
we've been struggling with for decades
and suddenly they've come in and they've
they haven't solved it i wouldn't quite
say but they you know they've made
significant strides
and the fact they've done it in just a
few years suggests there are significant
more strides to come if they can keep on
squeezing those performance gains out of
the ai
and we're just going to get to a point
where we've got so much data we can
sequence genomes we can sequence you
know we can look at proteins
and we can combine all that together in
a computer and as i was writing this i
was thinking wow this just sounds like
total sci-fi we're going to need a
you know a huge model a computer model
that understands the whole of the
workings of the human body all of our
dna all of our proteins
we've got you know like 40 trillion
cells in our body all working together
you have to model every single one of
those and
you know i just thought they said this
is crazy we're not going to the cure for
aging is never going to arrive in time
but actually you know if you think that
that kind of idea is a bit pie in the
sky it's 50 years away
imagine i'm in my 30s now i'm you know
fully expecting even if nothing happens
in medicine i should still be alive in
my 80s
and that means that even if you think
that technology is 50 years away it
could be in time for a lot of people who
are alive today
and actually the way that you can get
more optimistic about this is um
because by the time we're 80 we're going
to have synthetic drugs that are able to
kill our senescent cells in fact we're
not just going to have the first
generation we have now we're going to
have much improved versions of those
things we'll probably have a few of the
other hallmarks sort of ticked off the
list at the same time
and that's going to mean that we live
longer and healthier lives and
i don't want to put a figure on it but
let's let's imagine that you live an
extra five years as a result of all that
stuff
and five years in good health that means
you know when we get to the age of 80
we might be biologically 75 or 70 so
we're a bit more able to take whatever
these new treatments are
and you know we might be alive in time
to take them basically um
so i don't think you know i don't want
to guarantee at all
we just got no idea it could be that
this stuff's completely impossible and
although it seems like we've got an idea
now we might get 10 years down the line
think oh jesus you know we just
we completely underestimated hallmark
number four we're screwed
but even if you think that some of these
developments are 50 years away
they could be in time to matter for a
hell of a lot of people are alive today
it's like biology or longevity's got a
hard problem
and that heart or how would you say you
know the great filter hypothesis
about why the fermi paradox exists why
there's no aliens out there
there could be that and we may have got
past it or we may be able to get to
or it may not exist uh yeah it'll be a
fascinating area
of research presumably as well it's a
really weird time to be
alive because we're at a point in
history where
i don't you know we're not a thousand
years away from curing aging i don't
think
i you know if i wanted to be like really
conservative i think in the year 2000
people's risk of death is not going to
depend on how long ago they were born
you're three thousand so the quote in
the year 3000 like that definitely
there's there's
and i'm saying that to be like so
thoroughly uncontroversial
but the question is is it going to be 50
years is it going to be 100 years is it
going to be 200 years
i think that's an open question and
because you know
say we reach the age of 200 through
whatever breakthroughs happen
it just seems remarkably unlikely to me
that we won't have made such huge
strides in biology and computation
that we can effectively expect to live
longer still so i'm not saying we will
make it to 200 but if we do
the possibility of us living much much
longer is just wide open i think
presumably for everyone who's listening
to this the longer that
we all live the better our chance at
being alive
longer if a cure is found exactly and
even if even if we don't get as far as a
cure like every year
you live in good health additionally
there are going to be new breakthroughs
in medicine
it might not even be breakthroughs in
aging it might be a new cancer treatment
or a new heart disease treatment
and i think because some a lot of people
like
there's there's a real risk of starting
to talk about immortality and that kind
of thing and
certainly a lot of journalists a lot of
podcast hosts are very keen to talk
about like really really long lifespans
and stuff that's sort of
on the edge of our ability to predict at
this point in time quite frankly
however if you look back in history this
is this is really uncontroversial
because people who are born in the 1930s
um a lot of those people survived
because vaccinations are starting to
come online you know if they
if they got infectious disease when they
were 20 they would have been just the
first few
inklings of antibiotics and that meant
that when they were 70 in the year 2000
there are a load of heart treatments
that were completely unimaginable
in the 1930s like talking of you know we
didn't put wheels on suitcases until the
70s
we didn't invent chest compressions
until the 1950s or 1960s
and they certainly weren't like
widespread use until the late 60s i was
stunned when i found that out
researching the book
because you just think it's the most
obvious thing in the world if your heart
which beats
stops beating why don't you physically
beat it for it effectively
and yet it took us thousands of years as
a species to come to that realization
and so if you uh that and what that
means i've got quite sidetracked but
what that means is that if you were
alive
in the year 2000 because of medical
developments that happened in the 1930s
40s and 50s
you were then able to benefit from a
whole load of new medical technology
that simply didn't exist at the time of
your birth
and i think you know whether or not
we're gonna live to a thousand or ten
thousand or
102 the fact is every year you stay
alive longer
is another opportunity for some medical
breakthrough to happen that could
benefit you
let's say i want to live as long as i
can what what do i do i want the full
monty
i think at the moment a lot of it is
just follow
the basic health advice you know make
sure you don't get too fat
make sure you get a bit of exercise
because what you find when you drill
down you don't smoke
you get down you drill down into what
all these different bits of health
advice mean and this is something that
actually really
fascinated me there's a chapter in the
book about health advice
and what's really fascinating to me is
that it's
all of the things that are best for your
health all of the things that you've
been told that you should do by your
doctor or your dentist or whatever
effectively slow down the aging process
so smoking
effectively obviously it hits your lungs
the worst it puts you at massively
increased risk of lung cancer it puts it
massively increases risk of other lung
diseases as well
but it also accelerates the aging
process globally it increases this
process called inflammation which you
know drives the aging process
it makes non-lung cancers more likely as
well it increases your risk of heart
disease
so effectively what a smoker does if you
you know smoke 20 a day
you're basically 10 years older your
biological age is 10 years higher than
your
chronological ages and so you suffer
from all those diseases of aging that
much sooner
and it's the same with all of this
health advice like making sure you eat
well making sure you exercise
is effectively slowing down the aging
process and you know there's five or ten
years to be gained by doing this stuff
but what i think is the most important
thing and it's easy to overlook because
i think
you know all of us are really i i'm
fascinated by diet reading
we're talking about dietary restriction
i was i got obsessed when i was writing
that bit of the book being like what is
the optimum diet
you know if i just read enough papers it
must be out there it must be in the
literature somewhere you know
and what i came away thinking actually
was we're going to have cured aging
before we know exactly what the optimal
diet is because there are just so many
variables there's protein there's carbs
there's fats
there's all the different vitamins and
nutrients there's when you eat them
there's how much of it you eat when
there's what you eat on which days it's
the number of variables is just
astronomical
and so what i think is the single best
bit of health advice which doesn't sound
like health advice it sounds a bit weird
but it's to campaign for more research
into aging
so wherever we are in the world write
your representative write to your mp
talk to your friends and family
um i know this sounds like i'm promoting
my book but get them to read my book the
reason being
the more people who understand that
treating aging is a thing
that we can do that we should be aiming
to do we're going to get a critical mass
you need voters to know this we need
politicians to know this
and that means they can give money to
the scientists who are working on this
stuff
and then you get to a point where what's
determining the length of your life
isn't
exactly whether you eat the right
combination of fruits and veg on the
right day of the week
it is the progress in biology it's the
process in aging biology
so the progress in aging biology
effectively and i ultimately think
that's going to make a far bigger
difference than any of the lifestyle
interventions that we could talk about
what about exercise what's the most
optimal form of exercise that you found
and again that's so tricky um i think
something that i
i certainly personally neglected was
strength training so
as you get older um your muscle mass and
your muscle strength
decreases um and it starts off
relatively benign but from your mid-30s
onwards it starts to decrease and when
you get into your 60s and 70s it really
starts to fall off a cliff
but what's surprising is that actually
um
that is to a significant extent optional
which means that if you
engage in strength training you can ward
off frailty in your muscles for
a substantial amount of time i even
found one study where they gave some
nonogenarians so people in their 90s
strength training
and they were able to walk faster they
were able to lift heavier weights
um you know it's not like they were
going down the gym and power lifting or
anything like that but they you know
their quality of life was substantially
improved by this strength training
intervention
and so it's never too late to start and
also yeah just just make sure that you
look after your muscles because they are
one of the things that's going to really
impact on your quality of life
going back to the diet thing and
especially the intermittent fasting
point that we came up with earlier
do you think there's a bit of a pascal's
wager going on
here it's like i don't know
if if it's going to work but it's
probably
not not going to work so i might as well
do it
yeah and that's the that's the really
frustrating thing about it isn't it it's
like infuriating
because i would i would go with that if
it was easy to stick to
but the problem is in addition to the
fact it might work and you might as well
give it a go
it is exhaustingly you know being that
hungry is just so tiring all of the time
and it's not like there are no
disadvantages at all so in
um i think the best studies actually are
of dietary restriction rather than
intermittent fasting which is just
because
intermittent fasting stuff is that
little bit newer and so the human trials
aren't quite there
you know if you ask me again in two
years i suspect we'll have a bit more to
go on
um but what they found in dietary
restriction trials
is that people sometimes lose a bit of
bone mass so they had a few people have
to like drop out of the trial because
they were losing bone mass
they had someone drop out of the trial
because they were getting anemic which
means they didn't have enough red blood
cells
um and the other thing it can do is
reduce immunity
so you know there's no point living
effectively indefinitely if you're then
just going to get the flu and die in any
way
or coronavirus these days of course so
it's not unfortunately it doesn't quite
come down to pascal's wager because
firstly it's just tiring and really dull
and secondly there are these sort of
these nasty disadvantages i mean it's
just not a no-brainer to try it
it seems to me that
those are exceptions rather than
common issues um certainly after
speaking to david sinclair a couple
years ago in harvard
i was like i was so eating the
or drinking the kool-aid the
calorie-free kool-aid of
intermittent fasting and you're right i
i know
somebody's who find it really easy
michaela peterson who's a good friend of
mine she
consistently does like four day fast or
seven day fasts and stuff
which is just yeah that's another
another level
but it really is i don't know man i
don't know i was
you've thrown a spanner in the works i
was i was all team team calorie
restriction now and uh
the stories i said something that
happened to me
in exactly this way um so calorie
restriction is really hard
um intermittent fasting is still quite
hard you're trying to not eat for a full
day
is really difficult but the 16 8 thing i
thought that sounds quite doable so
actually my wife and i decided to try
that um at the beginning of i think it
was i can't remember it was last month
or the month before
and literally the week we started doing
it and it's quite doable by the way and
just not having
just skip breakfast starting at 12 then
make sure you get your food in before 8
pm
um it's i was a bit hungry in the
mornings but i often used to skip
breakfast you know as a young young
adult
when i was irresponsible so that's um
it's just not that hard to do
but then literally that week a study
comes out saying we've done a proper
randomized trial of this
admittedly it's not necessarily
applicable to everybody because they
looked to only white people they looked
at
people who are slightly overweight to
see if it would reduce their weight and
what they found was basically didn't do
anything
the people are in the control group and
the people who are in the experimental
group during the 168.
they both had about the same trajectory
of their weight their inflammatory
markers in their blood were about the
same their cholesterol was all about the
same
um and you know that's not nails in the
coffin but the scientists who did the
experiments he said
i was taken in by sixteen eight fasting
i was completely convinced by it
but now we've done this experiment i'm
stopping today you are missing on
everyone's party today it's really it's
really annoying
it's not like and i don't want to i mean
it's it's really frustrating i feel like
i i don't know what we can do about it
because i don't think we're going to
have the evidence that tells us one way
or the other
and that means i think there are there
are some really compelling arguments
made by people who are like dr advocates
that you know so so for example this
study and resources monkeys there were
two studies done
one of them was done at uh the
university of wisconsin
and one of them was the national
institutes for aging and one of them
found that the monkeys lived longer
and one of them found that they didn't
they both found the monkeys lived
healthier by the way so let's you know
park that
we can we can still potentially look
forward to healthier lives but let's
talk about longevity now
there are there's enough in there's
enough differences between those studies
to like have dr advocates and skeptics
arguing until the end of time what's dr
because
dietary restriction sorry the reason i'm
pedantically calling it dietary
restriction
rather than calorie restriction is that
recent work has suggested it might be
proteins or amino acids
which is the important thing to restrict
so it just shows you this just this is
so complicated right
it's it sounds like alluringly simple
when you hear
rats say half as much they lived almost
twice as long boom but actually like
what is it about their diet that changed
in what exact way that conferred those
particular benefits
and that's how you end up in this mess
and these this monkey experiment
or these pair of monkey experiments is a
really great example of that because
so the nia monkeys they were fed a
relatively uncontrolled is unfair but
they're they're afraid a natural diet of
like fish and grain
and various bits and bobs which by its
nature is uncontrolled because obviously
you can't like create a fish that has a
particular
combination of nutrients inside every
single time and the monkeys
in the university of wisconsin version
were eating these sort of sciency
purified pellets
so they had you know fat and protein and
sugar in exactly predetermined amounts
and um the university of wisconsin
monkeys the ones who are on the control
group who are out
what they like were literally allowed to
gorge on as many of these fatty sugary
pellets as they wanted
and you can sort of see where i'm going
here these monkeys were on like the fast
food mcdonald's soft drinks diet they
had fatty sugary pellets all you can eat
stuffing them in
and that meant that the dietary
restriction group who are on a
restricted number of these pellets
was healthier and lived longer however
in the nia study where they were given
this slightly more diverse but slightly
less scientifically precise diet what it
turned out was
the dietary restricted monkeys were
healthier for longer but they didn't
live any longer
and so the simplest explanation of this
perhaps
is simplest and perhaps simplistic
explanation i should say
is that there's a sort of sliding scale
so if you're eating hamburgers and fries
and soft drinks all the time like
there's
wisconsin monkeys gorging on these uh
these little pellets
then you can benefit from restricting
your diet a bit if you're already eating
not too much of an unhealthy diet or a
reasonable amount of a basically healthy
diet
there's not much benefit to going
further that is one interpretation
however if you're a dietary restriction
proponent for whom i've got a lot of
time
then you go okay well actually there are
other problems the nia study too
one of them is their monkeys were from a
much more diverse background and they
are a much wider range of ages
so they started some of these monkeys on
their dietary restriction when they were
in you know late adulthood
and they also had monkeys from all
different parts of the world and
this if there is an effect this could
potentially obscure it because they
found that dietary restriction works
differently in different
um in different strains of mouse for
example
and so you can imagine that an indian
macaque and african macaque might have a
slightly different response to it
and so all of this just muddies the
waters and it means you can make quite a
convincing argument that actually
if we were to go back and do these
experiments properly we would find an
effect
but what it makes me think is that there
might be an effect i don't want to like
completely
rain on everyone's parade but if there
is an effect it's clearly not a doubling
of lifespan like we see in rats
because these are two groups of
scientists who did these experiments
they were trying in good faith to
replicate these
ideas they had slightly different
approaches granted and there are various
things you can quibble about
but if this doubles lifespan we'd know
about it right one of them might be a
bit less than the other one but we'd see
it we'd see the results in the
experiments
but given that the results a bit
equivocal
you know maybe at the absolute most
optimistic end you might get five or ten
more years
but if you're already eating a basically
healthy diet i think it's hard to expect
that you're going to like dramatically
alter your lifespan 3dr
what's unique about us every animal
the most comprehensive reliable effect
in biology is calorie restriction or
dietary restriction
to extend lifespan and then at some
point in our
like couple of recent histories worth of
evolutionary change
someone just put a bit of computer code
in that off now
yeah now we're wrecked what's different
yeah it's rubbish isn't it
the the way to sort of reassure yourself
a little bit is part of the reason
is probably that we are relative we're
incredibly long-lived for our sites
we're pushing the limits of that already
exactly and there was even a theory that
i think has now been debunked but that
maybe humans have already turned on a
lot of the mechanisms that underlie dr
in order to reach our extended
lifestyles that we have they've actually
gone back and had a look at that and it
isn't true
it's the right sort of way of thinking
about it because
um so firstly i think these results are
much more variable than they're
sometimes suggested
and i noticed this when i was doing some
research for the book because
there's this i'll tell you the simple
story and i'll tell you why it doesn't
quite work
the simple story is that the reason that
animals
have this response to reduced food
intake is imagine you're a mouse
you've got a maximum lifespan of a
couple of years you might only have a
lifespan of one year because you've got
predators and you've got disease and
that sort of stuff so you've got a very
very short lifespan
imagine there's a famine so there's a
season where for some reason there's not
enough food
there are two things you can do in that
season you can either have a last ditch
attempt at having some kids before you
starve to death
or you can hunker down you can engage
your dietary restriction response
and you can slow your aging in order
that you'll live that little bit longer
so you can survive until the next season
when food's hopefully plentiful again
and have some kids
and there's a serious advantage to that
second approach and that is that your
kids will then be born into an
environment where there isn't a famine
going on
so rather than just having them
immediately in the last act of
desperation
so the theory goes and it's not entirely
supported and there are dr opponents who
will fight back against this but the
idea is that if you're a short-lived
animal it's really important to have a
very flexible lifespan
with respect to how much food you're
eating because if you're going through a
famine you need to survive
much longer you know a significant
fraction of your lifespan in order to
get to a point where you can have kids
and it'd be useful
however if you're a human and even in
prehistory
as you rightly said you know because of
a lot of infant mortality our life
expectancy was 35 but actually if you
made it out of
childhood or you made it past 15 then
you could expect to probably live into
your 40s or 50s and that means if you
have a famine for one year
like it's not ideal but it's not a
significant fraction of your
reproductive lifespan
and so you'd expect that as organisms
get longer lived
they might get less of a response to
dietary restriction as well
and what you also find when you look at
the data which makes it more confusing
is that this this sort of tight
correlation between lifespan and size
and the tight correlation between
um lifespan and dietary restriction
response doesn't really hold very
clearly
so dogs for example which we've also
tried dietary restriction in
has they has a surprisingly small effect
and i don't think anyone really knows
why
and actually there are lots of animals
that have a really big response and a
really small response and it's not quite
as neat as it seems at first glance even
though it is
incredibly universal the size of the
response can vary very
significantly i love that theory it
makes complete
sense and i'm a a big advocate for
evolutionary biology and evolutionary
psychology so
i'm seduced by that it's plausible but
everything today's come with a caveat
there's not a single thing
that's being definitive except for oh a
couple of studies
and even the studies while this could
have been different and that could have
been different yeah yeah yeah
so yeah it's strange that something
that's
let's say the prime vector of so much
suffering and
a universal a ubiquity across all of our
lives
is also something that we're incredibly
ignorant and all of the waters are
still very muddy about oh that's
something actually what about
supplements and drugs nmn nad
resveratrol metformin baby aspirin
the the david sinclair stack
i think we haven't got enough evidence
to go for those i personally don't take
any of them
i think that the evidence could get
there in the next few years but we need
to see human trials
there have been a few experiments in
mice that david's done that have shown
some effect i don't think they've shown
longevity on any of those things
it's like re-growing and stick nerves
and mad [ __ ] like that isn't it but
yeah crucially that was with gene
therapy rather than with a drug i'm
actually
i'm much much more excited by the
epigenetic reprogramming stuff than i am
by things like nmn
because i feel like the epigenetic
reprogramming seems to be going in and
fixing something about our biology
and it's not to say that nmn has no
effect it's something that declines with
age and
it's clearly you know something that
it's potentially going to improve uh
health and lifespan but i just don't
think we have the evidence yet that's
not again to say it doesn't work this is
me being
extremely pedantic scientist um but we
just need to wait until we see human
trials in order to be absolutely sure
my feeling with all of these things is
that
if you're a young person today
especially you can afford to hold off
because we're gonna know the answer to a
lot of these questions in the next five
or ten years
and your your aging at the moment is
relatively under control right you know
you're
you're young everything's basically fine
health-wise the fascinating question to
me is like what would i do if i was 65
or 70
and then i'd really be scratching my
head take everything because
take it take it it does turn everything
don't eat turn into much more of a
pascal's wager at that point because
so the i think the one that i'm
most excited is the wrong word but like
the thing that we're going to know about
in the
in the nearest term that might be
beneficial is metformin
which is this diabetes drug that looks
as though it might slow down aging and
there's a massive trial that's going to
start in the u.s
shortly i think it's been delayed
because of covid but it's going to be
looking at whether if you give
healthy 60 somethings this metformin
drug
will it slow down the rate at which they
get cancer and heart disease and various
other things
because there's been some suggestive
evidence that it's normally as i said
given to diabetics
and there's been some suggestive
evidence that shows that these diabetics
who are taking the drug
can actually live longer than
non-diabetics and the thing about
non-diabetics is they tend to be you
know they tend to be less overweight
they tend to be a bit fitter they tend
to be healthier to have less other
diseases
and yet even still the diabetics on
metformin in a couple of studies have
marginally outlived them which suggests
that maybe if you gave the metformin to
a healthy person
they'd live even longer still but that's
again something we're just going to know
the answer to in five years time this
trial
should be done by then and so if you're
a young person
there's not really any incentive to
start you know knocking back the
metformin but if i were 65
i mean there definitely are people out
there on the internet who go to their
doctor and ask for them to prescribe the
metformin even though they're not
diabetic
and i wouldn't want to advocate that but
i can certainly see why it's you know
why it's a temptation at that point
one of the things that fascinated me
especially after my episodes with david
sinclair
is how passionate the longevity
community is on the internet
there's very few episodes that i've ever
put out that have evoked
such a visceral emotional response and
i i became really interested in it and
as we released more clips
through 2018 and into 2019 i became
increasingly interested because each
time a clip went up
there were people who were even about
things that weren't to do with the
episodes the camera angle or whether or
not i touched the microphone
there were people who were really really
obviously just on
edge and agitated generally about this
topic
really really annoyed about the fact
that i hadn't digged into the precise
microgrammage of
this particular drug that david was
taking or whatever it might be
do you think that longevity
is another or the longevity movement is
kind of another denial of death
is it a replacement for religion in
people
fearing what happens next are they
pinning their hopes onto science now as
the new god
it's a good question i think it's
there's obviously a huge spectrum
from i i mean as you can see as you said
earlier i caveat everything i'm
i'm a 100 like extremely cautious
scientist or at least i try as hard as i
can to be
um but there are definitely people who
take these early results and run with
them
and i it's a it is a fascinating bit of
psychology because i'm not motivated by
death per se i think i got interested in
this stuff because i
i realized that there is this underlying
biology that gives rise to all these
different diseases
and fundamentally um you might have
heard the statistic that aging
is responsible for about two-thirds of
deaths globally and that fraction is
only increasing
as the global population ages and it's
it's that sort of thing that
fundamentally got me into it
so i find it hard to appear into the
psychology of someone who
i mean death can be scary it's it's a
bizarre thing to think about ceasing to
exist
and i think this philosophical idea that
you know you won't know it doesn't
matter because you won't be there
i still you know don't like don't
particularly enjoy peering into the
abyss and it's not something i'm looking
forward to
and i find it very strange like the
converse attitude
i've got a lot of sympathy for people
who don't want to die um
but there are quite a lot of people who
like push back and say why are you
working on aging you know isn't death
what gives life
meaning and that sort of thing and i
just find that side of things completely
baffling
because i think there's there's almost
nothing where if you were
pursuing some goal that was going to
reduce the amount of death in the world
that anyone would criticize it like if i
i think a world
which is exactly the same as today in
every respect but there's a bit less
death
it's probably a better world like i
don't think that's me being a zany mad
like immortalist scientist
saying that and yet there are some
people who really push back in the other
direction as well so i think there's a
it's a complicated relationship we've
got with this thing that's been a fact
of life
like for as long as there has been life
it's not even like humanity this is
spanning over it's literally the whole
of
the existence of biology there has been
death
and so i just think yes it's really
fascinating that we're now at a point in
history
where you know we're not sewing monkey
testicles to people to try and make them
live longer we're not like giving them
weird combinations of herbs
yeah in the 1920s there was a big place
trying to work out whether monkey
testicles oh yeah
yeah where i'm actually not 100
it was quite hard it wasn't the details
it wasn't a straight swap was it
i don't i don't think so no because i
mean the thing is you probably want to
keep your own wouldn't you because
they're useful
a monkey's monkey testicles the ones
that are huge
they are aren't they do you know what
i'm actually not sure what the logic was
at all behind this idea
anyone who knows anything about monkey
testicles please leave it in the
comments
below yeah please please write in have
you i'd love to get lots of
correspondence have you considered
philosophically what would happen to the
way that we
view our lives and the meaning that's
associated with them
if we were to make a leap in terms of
lifespan
if we're talking we go from an average
of 80 to 160 or to 200.
what do you think that that would sort
of mean for us
do you know what i don't think it would
make much difference
and that sounds like a strange answer
but i think because and this sort of
goes back to the death gives life
meaning
idea like when you go for a job
interview
or when you ask someone on a date or
when you you know do basically anything
in your life
it's very rare for you to be doing that
because you know that you're going to
die in 50 years time
i don't think that acts as a motivator
and i live my life
like not not wanting to sound like some
kind of headache i just live it day to
day like mostly i get up in the morning
i look at my calendar i see what i've
got to do
i've got a bit of an idea of what's
coming up in the next month you might
plan a holiday three months in advance
you might plan a house move a bit
further in advance than that i'm saving
for my pension
but like ultimately i'm not giving my
day-to-day life at the age of 60 a very
great deal of thought
and so i think if i was going to live to
160 or 560
i just i i think i'd probably continue
living day to day and week to week like
it would change some things about
the way that i the way that we function
in society but i think ultimately i'd
still you know go on holiday try and
have new experiences
i can't think it would make that massive
an amount of difference to how we live
one thing i don't think people plan for
the long term that much now
that's a that's a very very correct
observation and i suppose that's
adaptive as well
if you don't know how long you've got
left to live it's pointless
having this unbelievable long-term
planning module
slotted into the back of your brain yeah
one one thing that i'd considered
was um how we might
fear accidents much more
because the cost of an accident i'm 32
let's say i get hit by a bus tomorrow
you know if i'm unlucky with my normal
lifespan i've got about fifty percent so
forty fifty percent of the way there
yeah got bad yeah you know
it's all right like i've got a bit but
if your lifespan
is 200 or 500 years
the prospect of an accident i wonder
whether downstream from that culturally
uh societally we would be so much more
protective
over exposing ourselves to pathogens and
viruses
over doing scary things because the
weight of how much you have to lose is
so much greater
yeah definitely and i'm i'm that makes
me quite optimistic actually that is one
way in which i think things would change
for for the positive socially because
another example is war
like the reason that we consider war an
acceptable thing to the extent that we
do
is because like you say if you were to
go into war even as a 20 year old
you haven't lost you know two 300 years
of future life
whereas if we start having casualties in
wars and that's the sort of scale of the
tragedy
not to take anything away from the
tragedy of dying in battle now but
i really think it would surely cause us
at that point to sit down and think
what on earth are we doing transhumanism
and artificial intelligence uploading
our minds
to the skynet and getting arnold
schwarzenegger down
versus beating ageing to
get us to live over 200 years which one
do you think comes first
i hope we do it biologically and
the reason is actually quite
philosophical and i say i hope we do it
biologically unless i'm
unless the philosophy can be sorted out
to my satisfaction because my concern is
um with mind uploading firstly it's just
weird like i quite like being especially
biological
i think you know maybe this is the
evolutionary psychology speaking and
i've got used to like living in this
weird floppy whatever the hell it is
that we live in but i'm quite
comfortable with that i don't
particularly want to be uploading the
computer
the second sort of deeper philosophical
issue with it is
imagine you did copy my every neuron
into some computer program
and then that computer program you know
you could have done that interview with
the computer program instead it would
give you all the same down answers or at
least ones that were indistinguishable
in terms of cognition but is that
computer program actually me
and i think when if you're scared of
dying and i think
so what i think is morally significant
about death is that i think we should
avoid
terminating consciousnesses because
conscious beings they've got plans
they've got dreams you don't want to you
know cut that off and mean they can no
longer have any freedom any plans any
dreams etc
so that's something you want to avoid
doing and if you were to upload someone
into a computer
and then maybe discard their biological
brains you don't need it anymore
you've got absolutely no guarantee that
consciousness has continued
and philosophers have got some ideas of
how to get around this which is for
example you know
it might be that we have brain computer
interfaces at some point in the next 100
years
and maybe i could plug in a brain
computer interface it'll give me you
know access to the internet or give me
some additional memory capacity or i
could play the piano which i can't
currently do or whatever
and slowly i'd replace my neurons one at
a time with an electronic equivalent
and you end up with a situation where if
you do it gradually perhaps you do get a
continuity of consciousness
but if you do it all at once the
question is you know would you just
disappear
the the philosophical question which
i've never seen answered to my
satisfaction
is even if you do do this sort of
gradual not death but sort of life by a
thousand cuts as you slowly
insert the computer into your head like
is it definitely the case that i will
still be alive at the end of that
or will there be some weird cyborg
andrew steele who's
like philosophically indistinguishable
as i said you know we could literally
have this conversation
but somehow isn't me and therefore i am
dead
in the sense that we currently
understand it and
i'm until someone can convince me that
that's the case i'm happy in my squishy
biological brain thank you very much
the maddest thing about consciousness is
that if we weren't experiencing it
firsthand phenomenologically everyone
that is listening understands what it is
like
to think and know that you are thinking
to be a bundle of matter that is aware
of its own existence
if it wasn't for the fact that we feel
that as an experience
we would be completely ignorant of the
fact that it exists
that yeah that's terrifying it's
remarkable um another thing i think
you just said there about the fact that
terminating consciousness is something
that is very meaningful when it comes to
death
does that mean it is a moral duty for
all of us
to live as long as we can and to
maximize our life
that's an interesting question it
depends on your school of ethics
basically
and there's a really fascinating and
naughty school of ethics
called population ethics which looks at
these sort of questions population wide
and there's a huge amount of controversy
i'm not an expert in it and there's a
you know we could if you get a
philosopher on and you could talk about
it for a couple of hours with them
but to give you two examples one school
of population ethics says that you
should
maximize utility and what they mean by
utility is
basically happiness you can again talk
to a philosopher for 35 minutes about
what they mean by utility is basically
happiness they want to maximize
happiness
and what that means is you want to have
the largest possible number
of happy beings and sometimes that means
they're quite relaxed about death
actually because they're not bothered
about terminating consciousness as long
as you replace them
with other happy consciousnesses because
there's no sort of requirement for
continuity
another school of population ethics is
called average utility maximization
which is that rather than saying we want
to have the maximum possible utility
we just want the average to be the
highest and both so and both of these
lead to quite counterintuitive
conclusions sometimes
because you could end up if you want to
maximize utility i could imagine some
world
where we have 25 trillion people and
they're all
just above being utterly horribly
depressed
but because they are just above that
when you combine them all together
the overall happiness is greater than a
world of 7 billion people
who are all much much happier than any
of those 25 trillion are
so that's the sort of bizarre conclusion
you get with maximizing utility
if you want to average utility instead
you can get another bizarre conclusion
which is that the imagine that i'm you
know euphorically happy all the time
that's my disposition
then if we murdered everyone else on
planet earth and i was the only one who
has left because i'm euphorically
brought the average up we've just
exactly the average is like as high as
it can possibly be
so clearly both of these things lead to
like these incredibly unpalatable moral
conclusions right
so i and basically the jury's out the
philosophers are still arguing about it
and they may be arguing for some time
because that's what philosophers do
but i think it's yeah it's it's really
really difficult to work out like what
our moral duty is in this regard
and so that's that's actually one of the
reasons that i really care about aging
because one of we could like i said
earlier i think we can all agree that
less death would probably be a good
thing and i think we can all agree
even more than that you know even if
you're chill about death which you know
some people are because they don't exist
or they think they won't exist then we
all know that suffering is bad
and aging is the single largest cause of
suffering in the world
so you don't need to you know break out
the population ethics philosophers in
order to
get behind the idea that's something
that's worth doing something about yeah
that's
the second order effect of somebody
passing away is
the people around them the people that
care their dependents
all of those people are left traumatized
and upset yeah and
that is what led me to ask about is
our moral duty to to live as healthy and
long of a life as possible
yeah no i think that's right and i think
that's that's something that it's almost
a bit selfish to be like i'm not worried
about dying because i won't be around
you're like yeah but everyone you love
and care about will be around and they
probably won't be that you know best
pleased
you're totally right man so andrew today
has been really really fun ageless
the new science of getting older without
getting old oh do you know what you've
got you've got a uh a pre-release cup
let's have a look at this let's have a
look this is what it actually looks like
you see that yeah yeah it's got a
tortoise on it yeah so that's our
negatively senescent tortoise oh hang on
i'm pointing on the wrong side that's my
negligence taught us yeah there you go
very cool it's actually a quote from
andrew scott on the front of the book
what to say
it says read it and prepare to think
differently about your future
it's such a uh incestuous little
community this is a
longevity thing isn't it between andrew
scott and you and david sinclair
can't get away from you people want to
check out your stuff where should they
go
the book will be linked in the show
notes below of course go and get it on
amazon if you buy it through that link
you will be supporting this show at no
extra cost to yourself
what else do you want to plug you can
find me on twitter i'm at stato
st a tto and i've also got a youtube
channel which is uh youtube.com
dr andrew steele all one word so yeah
check it all out amazing thank you mate
thank you very much have a good one
you